ja wir kommen zur aktuellen vorlesungen
heute geht es um die ästhetik der
digitalität den zweiten teil und
computerspiele in der letzten sitzung
hatten wir uns auch schon der
ästhetische digitalität beschäftigt
jedoch aus anderen gesichtspunkt auf den
ich heute auch noch mal rückblickend zu
sprechen komme da hatten wir es nämlich
mit virtuellen kurz und damit will ich
jetzt nicht sagen dass auch
computerspiele keine virtuelle kunst
während das diesen sicherlich virtuelle
kunst aber und der virtuelle kunst kann
man sie auch andere dinge verstehen oder
vor allem andere dinge verstehen als
computerspielen auf die
kunstformen virtuelle art komme ich
heute noch mal kurz zu sprechen dann
geht es zum eigentlichen thema der
ästhetik der digitalität zweiten teil
computerspielen und
abschließend zeige ich noch was zur
nächsten sitzung der s und die
anthropologie der digitalität geht und
auch am rande um bewegungen des
transformers muss wieder so fischer
theorien dazu das gehört auch noch in
eine vorlesung über digitalität ja noch
mal als rückblick zur letzten sitzung
wir hatten da ein paar phänomene
virtueller kunst uns angeschaut einmal
fc st anfangs übertrug und dann hatten
wir noch die ästhetik der künstlich
entwickeln thematisiert ich möchte noch
ganz allgemein was sagen zum verhältnis
von digitalität und kunst wenn die
digitalisierung wegen den letzten
sitzung besprochen hatten und diskutiert
hatten einen virtuellen handlungsraum
eröffnet dafür spricht einiges dann
eröffnet sie damit natürlich auch einen
virtuellen handlungsraum für kunst oder
einen virtuellen kunstraum das scheint
mir ganz klar zu sein jetzt muss man
sich allerdings fragen welchen status
hat virtuelle kunst in meinen augen kann
man sie nur schlecht auf die technik der
digitalisierung reduzieren also auf
software oder hardware durch die sie
realisiert wird oder dass sie an
bedeutung verlieren natürlich kann man
am anfang steht die tokens auf software
reduzieren durch oder auf code
reduzieren auf dem sie passieren aber
das wären stark reduktionistischen
zugang der etwa
solchen reduktionistischen zugang ähnelt
dem man auch bei gemälden von picasso
zugrunde liegen könnte auch da könnte
man sagen das ist doch nichts anderes
als farbe auf einer alten lion war
genauso wie es in meinen augen auch wenn
man sagen würde ein virtuelles kunstwerk
ist doch nur code realisiert in einer
maschine das würde diesem ästhetischen
dieser ästhetischen dimension dieser
städtischen qualität dieses virtuellen
kunstwerks nicht gerecht
allerdings besteht wohl doch ein
unterschied zwischen physisch
realisierter kunst und virtueller kunst
insofern nämlich die virtuelle kunst
einer anderen raumzeit logisch gehorcht
als es die physische konstrukt könnte
man hier noch weitere gedanken sich
machen und sich fragen ist nicht kunst
sei sie jetzt physisch realisiert oder
auch anders realisiert ist sie nicht
immer schon virtuell also impliziert
nicht kunst als solche eine form von
virtualität
spannende frage darüber werden halt auch
noch mehr sagen wenn es um computer
spiele geht ich glaube dass man diese
these vertreten kann dann aber genau den
begriff des virtuellen bestimmen muss
eben nicht verstanden als eine
simulation sondern als eine andere form
von realisierung und so verstanden kann
tatsächlich jede form von kunst auch
virtuell sinne gedacht werden das würde
jetzt aber zu weit führen dass noch
weiter auszuarbeiten wir können der und
begangen im anschluss diskutieren es
komme ich auf mein erstes beispiel der
letzten fotos und versprechen mfps das
ist ein nicht austauschbar aus das heißt
individuelles und einmaliges dick
digitales unikat in der regel
sind ja digitale objekte auf virtuelle
objekte wenn sie im digitalen raum
existieren prinzipiell ununterscheidbar
kopierbar sie haben dieselbe anzahl von
bits und bytes und wir können unendlich
viele kopien identische kopien von
diesen objekten machen
ohne dass wir sie mir wirklich
unterscheiden können das ist bei nfc ist
nicht der fall sie sind gewissermaßen
eine analogie zum verein physisch welt
zu verstehen dass also dass da versucht
individualität und auch originalität in
die sphäre der digitalität zu
importieren da gibt es auch mechanismen
das zu realisieren
die individualisierung oder auch dieses
unikats wesen stellten das werde
digitalität eine besondere
herausforderung dar weil die
digitalisierung wie gesagt die tendenz
hat die karten zu vermeiden alles
letztendlich auch reproduzierbar zu
machen das ist ein zug der digitalität
jetzt habe ich ein beispiel eines mfps
das ist dieses bildnis every day is the
first days von mike winkelmann das ist
eine collage aus 5000 kleineren
digitalen bildern die zu über 42.000
täter die heute momentan ein gegenwert
von knapp 70 millionen us dollar haben
versteigert wurde quelle wikipedia sehen
wenn sie genau hin scheint ganz viele
kleinere bilder sondern das ist ein um
die combicard insofern eben nicht
beliebig reproduzierbar ist das nicht
mein unterschied festzustellen dass das
hat dann mit mit cash summen und so
weiter zu tun mit verschiedenen software
lösungen dass man das realisieren kann
das muss uns nicht so sehr interessieren
die tatsache ist nur es ist möglich auch
im raum der digitalität kunst unikate zu
erstellen und er merkt dieser
mainfrankens der bund der nimmt zu also
virtuelle kunst es auf dem vormarsch man
muss schauen wie das in einigen
jahrzehnten aussieht ob man dann nur
noch virtuelle kunst bei sich zu hause
hat teilweise sind es auch nur ganz
kleine entitäten also nicht so große
oder aufwändige bilder teilweise sehr
kleine kunstwerke die auch für sehr hohe
summen an gehandelt werden als virtuelle
kunst dieses projekt habe ich auch schon
erklärt das ist die versucht beethovens
nun vollendete zehnte sinfonie mit hilfe
von künstlicher intelligenz zu ende zu
komponieren
ich nach oben rechts dann noch mal mit
links oder sie zum reinen warum anderen
seminare habe ich dazu ausführlicher was
gesagt und man kann sich jetzt über die
ästhetische qualität dieser künstlich
erzeugten vollendeten 10 toni streiten
ich finde es nicht so sonderlich
originell aber es ist ein erster schritt
auch die digitalität im bereich der
virtuelle kunst anzuwenden mit hilfe von
künstlicher intelligenz
ja das heißt wenn wir jetzt wieder
reflektieren auf das allgemeine
verhältnis der
mensch-maschine-interaktion
dann bedeutet das dass auch dieses
verhältnis von mensch und künstliche
intelligenz und der ästhetischen
gesichtspunkten werden kann nicht nur
aus erkenntnistheoretischen oder
ökonomischen gesichtspunkten
kunstschaffende künstlerinnen und
künstler und künstliche intelligenz
verhalten sich meinen augen nicht wie
subjekt und objekt zueinander oder wieso
geht um instrument das wäre wieder ein
zuseher reduktionistischen zugang zu
dieser ästhetischen menschen entschieden
interaktion vielmehr bilden sie einen
kreativen zusammenhang im sinne
kooperativer virtueller kunstproduktion
künstlich dirigent wird zu einer art
virtuellen moses einer virtuellen
inspirationsquelle dadurch dass eben auf
basis zahlreicher
datengrundlagen modifikation variation
transformation ermöglichen die den
künstler oder die künstlerin inspirieren
können variation ist ja in der kunst ein
ganz wichtiges moment und dazu kann die
künstliche intelligenz beitragen das
bedeutet sie ist an sich nicht kreativ
zu nämlich glaube ich dass man
künstliche intelligenz kreativen kann
ich glaube auch nicht dass es künstliche
kreativität gibt im strengen sinne wie
es zum beispiel ganz beträgt der
reflektierenden urteilskraft sagen dass
ich etwas gegeben ein überbegriff bilde
den es noch gar nicht gibt
das ist die kreativität der urteilskraft
künstlichen intelligenz besitzen meinen
augen keine reflektierende urteilskraft
nur bestimmende urteilskraft wie auch
immer dennoch lässt sich künstliche
intelligenz sehr gut und zwar nahtlos in
kreative prozesse integrieren nicht nur
als ein instrument das uns körperlich
ist sondern als ein bestandteil ein
moment künstliche intelligenz auch wenn
sie nicht kreatives im strengen sinne
kann immerhin überraschen und neue
perspektiven erzeugen die als
inspiration für unser weiteres
kunstschaffen dienen können ja jetzt
hatte ich hier noch ein paar
fragen überlegt für die heutige
vorlesung in der es um den zweiten teil
der ästhetik der digitalität gehen soll
der dem thema computerspiele gewidmet
lässt in der erste frage ist welche
philosophische bedeutenden sitzen spiele
überhaupt spiele ganz eigen macht
welche philosophische bedeutung besitzen
computerspiele im besonderen sind
computerspiele medien also ist ein
medien theoretische zugang zu
computerspielen adäquat sagt er uns
alles aus was wir philosophisch über
computerspiele wissen oder kräfte nicht
zu kurz wie verhalten sich
computerspiele zur simulation illusion
fiktion und virtuelle realität virtuelle
realität ist ja unser schlüsselbegriff
mit dem wir uns zu blickte digitalität
erschlossen haben inwiefern simulieren
computerspielen realität
wie verhalten sich nutzer und
computerspiele zueinander also nur
zerrinnt nutzer sind sie nur
letztendlich äußerlich den
computerspielen oder werden sie
einbezogen durch die version inwiefern
sind computerspiele teil einer kultur
der digitalität der felix stalder
gesprochen hatte ich nach oben rechts
den link zur ersten sitzung der wir uns
in diesem thema befasst haben hinein wie
fernsehen computerspiele gar teil einer
lebensform sie sehen computerspiele
werden immer mehr teil unseres lebens
ich denke das ist unbestritten jetzt
müssen wir mal kurz auf die erste frage
eingehen was ist überhaupt das
philosophisch besondere am spiel
bringen ein zitat der mensch die nur
wollen voller bedeutung des wortes
mensch ist und er ist nur da ganz mensch
wo er spielt sie dürfen teil mal raten
von wem dieses zitat stammt
es ist von niemand geringerem als
friedrich schiller in seinen briefen
über die ästhetische erziehung des
menschen natürlich kann man sich jetzt
überlegen was bedeutet jetzt hier
spielen in diesem kontext ist es das
spiel als zeitvertreib ist es das spiel
als gesellschaftsspiel er fußball spielt
oder es das spiel auf einer bühne des
schauspiels das muss man sich fragen
ohne frage jedenfalls ist das spiel
wichtig ist die spielerische dimension
der menschlichen existenz zentral
weswegen man von einer anthropologie des
spiels sprechen kann im spiel entwirft
sich der mensch in seiner freiheit sagt
der schüler ich glaube dass dazu aber
was heißt jetzt freiheit im kontext des
begriffs des spiels im spiel
experimentiert der mensch mit
möglichkeit und wirklichkeit er kann
also die wirklichkeit übersteigen durch
fiktionen durch andere formen von
realisierung so dass das spiel schon ein
bisschen richtung virtuelle realität
hinweist einfach weil wir uns von der
wirklichkeit lösen allerdings ist es
eben doch immer nur ein spiel und das
spiel wird gemeinhin der wirklichkeit
entgegengesetzt es ist jedenfalls ein
spiel das spiel mit mensch und
möglichkeit und wirklichkeit jetzt kann
man sich fragen stellen computerspiel
eine neue form von spielern oder fügen
sich computerspiele in diese tradition
des spiels die auch schiller in seinem
zitat angesprochen hat worin besteht
also die besonderheit von
computerspielen im gegensatz etwa zu
brettspielen wie schach ist ja auch ein
spiel und vielleicht nicht mal so ein
banales spielen ganz im gegenteil schach
ist eines der komplexesten spiele go ist
vielleicht noch komplexer es ist
jedenfalls nicht nur eine spielerei
wirtschaft gut spielt der bekommt
respekt gezogen es ist was anderes als
ein triviales spielen sei ein sehr
komplexes spiel spielen können sehr
komplex seien
dennoch stellt sich die frage wie
verhalten sich jetzt computerspiele zu
brettspielen wie schach sind
computerspielen spiele oder viel mehr
als das was sind sie dann genau wenn sie
mehr sind als nur spiel setzt jetzt
immer natürlich voraus man muss den
spiel begriff klären und der
spielbetrieb ist nicht trivial wie wir
anhand des schachspiels gesehen haben
dennoch ist schach sicherlich kein teil
und zur lebenswelt über nur von den
allerwenigsten personen teil einer
lebens sind das scheint sich beim
computerspiel so langsam zu ändern
glaube ich jedenfalls wir müssen dieser
frage im rahmen der heutigen vorlesung
weiter nachgehen jetzt möchte ich so ein
paar einführende literatur ihnen
vorstellen zum computerspielen sie
kennen sicherlich die reihe von junius
verlag tam zur einführung habe ich auch
mal ein buch darüber geschrieben
theorien des bösen hier gibt's jetzt
theorien des computerspiels von gamestop
das ist also eine kooperative ehrlich
literatur von verschiedenen autorinnen
autoren zu diesem themenkomplex möchte
hier aus der einleitung ein zitat
vorlesen was ist das computerspiel diese
ausgangsfrage mag der leser am beginn
eines bandes zu einführen die theorien
des computerspiels erwarten ist es wie
der name nahelegt in erster linie ein
spiel oder sind gerade moderne
computerspiele ihre interaktive
erzählungen oder ist vielleicht eine
ganz andere kategorie der beschreibung
etwa die der simulation angemessen an
welche eine solche definition ließen
sich problemlos bestimmte disziplin
nähere informationen der gamestar ist
anschließend etwa ökologische respektive
spiele theoretische ansätze
pathologische untersuchung oder auch
hessens und immersion konzepte die sich
mit dem eintauchen des spielers in
seinem spiel welt beschäftigt auf den
begriff der immigration den eintauchen
des spielers in die spielwelt combo
heute noch genauer zu sprechen pluto
logisch bedeutet also ihre theoretische
spiele analysis gittern das spiel den
prozess die aktivität des spiels und
simulationen begriff hatten wir auch
schon gehört das ist natürlich auch ein
wichtiger begriff wir müssen versuchen
diese fragen zu klären
es gibt schreibt diese einführende band
einen streit zwischen ludo logen und
marathon logan der sich an der frage
entzündet hat ob es sich bei
computerspielen um spiele oder erzählung
handelt ja was ist das das ist eine
spannende frage ich persönlich tendiere
dazu es weniger als erzählungen zu
verstehen spiele sondern vielmehr als
spiele aber natürlich noch mehr als
spiele warum nicht so sehr erzählung
weil der spieler oder die spielerin im
spiel seine eigene geschichte immer mehr
bildet erschafft so dass er sie nicht
vorgesetzt bekommen sondern die
spielerinnen und der spieler selbst
aktiv ihre erzählung im spielen
konstituieren also man kann durchaus
sagen es hat etwas mit erzählung zu tun
aber die erzählung ist uns nicht
vorgegeben sondern wir sind selbst autor
unserer spiele erzählen so scheint mir
wird das ganze adäquat dargestellt ich
möchte noch ein zitat ihr lesen der
multidisziplinäre charakter der gamestar
ist manifestiert sich inzwischen in
einer vielzahl von methoden und
forschungsperspektiven neben den
genannten fragen nach der logi zieht
also der
spielzeit der spiele natur und
narrativer tät der erzählstruktur oder
erzählen natur von spielen geht es um
die medialität und intermedialität die
bildlichkeit und auditive tät des
computerspiels und darstellung seiner
geschichte seines designs seines
einflusses auf identitäts und gender
konstruktion und seiner die fusion in
die populärkultur es gibt rezeptions wie
produktions ästhetisch ernährungsweisen
genauso wie empirisch
sozialwissenschaftlich ansetzen
computerspiele forscherin entstanden den
literatur film kunst oder
medienwissenschaften der pädagoge der
soziologie der
kommunikationswissenschaft oder der
informatik und natürlich auch die
philosophie muss man hier zu setzen
alles ist ein interdisziplinärer zugang
der immer mehr sich die computerspielen
als einer gesellschaftlichen realität
widmet das ist ganz wichtig also wenn
wir so viele ansätze darauf an wänden
auf das phänomen ist computerspiels
bedeutet ist dass das computerspiel in
der mitte unserer gesellschaft
angekommen ist noch ein zitat und
genauso vielfältig wie die mit dem
computerspiel befassten wissenschaften
zeigt sich schließlich der
untersuchungsgegenstand selbst dass ich
mittlerweile nur noch in begrenztem maße
durch eine einteilung nach
spielprinzipien die action strategie
oder adventure spielen oder eine
auflistung bestimmter meilensteine der
computerspielgeschichte beschreiben
lässt sind viele weitere kategorien
etwas simpel multiplayer kerschl
hauptproblem und oder auch den bereich
des serious games hervorgebracht hat und
sich mit dem siegeszug der smartphones
und social games stetig seite aus
situation also hier handelt es sich
gewissermaßen eine
soziologie
der computer spiele die man anstellen
kann natürlich auch eine typologie der
computerspiele also es ist ein großer
forschungsgegenstand geworden dass
computerspiele ich möchte noch weitere
perspektiven bringen die er jetzt
philosophischer natur sind eine von
dramatik folge ein buch mit dem titel
computerspiele eine ästhetik also hier
wird das computerspiele ästhetischen
gesichtspunkten er handelt auch hier
möchte ich im zitat vorlesen
computerspiele sind zu einem weltweit
verbreiteten phänomen beim erscheinen
einer neuen spielkonsole stehen menschen
mit vielen ländern vor den geschäften
schlange lange bevor diese öffnen in
südkorea führen virtuosen des
computerspiels ganze staaten mit
zuschauer hierzulande nur beim fußball
und die ankündigung von fortsetzungen
etablierter spiele serien geraten heute
zu großereignissen auf messen und im
internet nicht zuletzt bringt die
computerspiele mittlerweile in umsatz
region vor die idee nur der musik und
filmindustrie vorbehalten war
computerspieler sind im mainstream
angekommen und bilden einen integralen
bestandteil der alltagskultur
hier wird auf dieses massenphänomen
hingewiesen dass computerspiels dass in
manchen ländern wie südkorea dimension
wie hierzulande der fußball angenommen
hat hier ist der denker das spiel
starcraft anstatt die spiel was hohe
anforderungen an die spielerinnen und
spieler steht und was von vielen auch
mit schach verglichen wird weil es so
viele strategien gibt um dieses spiel
eben erfolgreich zu
bewältigen
ein weiteres zitat mit computerspielen
ist ein neues ästhetisches medium
entstanden und die geburt ästhetischer
medien ist seit jeher von kritischen
stimmen begleitet worden den der
kulturelle wandel der mit diesen medien
einhergeht nicht geheuer war schon bei
der erfindung der fotografie und des
films wurde der untergang des
abendlandes aufgerufen ich stimme er ist
sehr zu es ist ein ästhetisches medium
und die besonderheit ist dass dass es
eben nicht trivial ist und die es hat
eine eigene ästhetische qualität die man
ernst nehmen sollte und man sollte
computerspiele nicht vorschnell
reduktionistischen als bloße spielerei
disqualifizieren damit würde man einen
bestandteil unserer realität aus klar es
wird also diesem phänomen nicht gerecht
die frage die sich medien erstellt ist
wird computerspiele wird man den
wirklich gerecht wenn man sie als ein
medium versteht diesen medien
theoretische frage die möchte ich hier
noch ein bisschen problematisieren
empfangen das ziel besteht jetzt in
diesem buch noch mal in einer
philosophischen analyse der ästhetischen
eigenarten des computerspiels das buch
unternehmen zu feige den versucht aus
der perspektive der philosophischen
ästhetik zu exportieren was
computerspiele wesentlich ist und jetzt
kommt die these einer philosophischen
analyse des computerspiels und seiner
ästhetischen eigenart geht es um eine
reflexive klärung der für unser
verständnis dieser ästhetischen eigene
art unverzichtbaren grundbegriffe also
der autor behauptet sich in den
computerspielen werden verschiedene
grundbegriffe der ästhetik thematisiert
thematisch wenn man eine philosophische
analyse dieses phänomens betrag es gibt
noch weitere ansätze einer philosophie
des computerspiels auch von herrn feige
mit fast in ostritz und markus rosenberg
herausgegeben philosophie des
computerspiels um der titel theorie
praxis ist tätig also hier wird versucht
die ganze philosophische an breite von
zugängen auf das computerspiel
anzuwenden auch hier ein paar zitate ist
da stellt sich erstens die frage
inwiefern das überhaupt ein sinnvolles
projekt ist philosophisch über
computerspiele nachzudenken in einer
abwandlung eines satzes von hegel könnte
man sagen dass es in der philosophie
doch um die ernsten zwecke die
herkömmlicherweise etwa mit das war das
gute und das schöne und nicht um das
gefällige spiel sind computerspiele nur
eine form von gefälligem spiel ich habe
spielerei genannt wenn computerspiele
ein neuartiges mediums sind worin
unterscheidet es sich von anderen medien
wenn computerspiele letztlich multipel
installierbare kann es sind auf welche
weise existieren sie dann genau wie
computerspielen virtuell ethisch gutes
oder schlechtes getan wird die verhalten
sich diese spiele handlungen zu
alltäglichen handlungen und deren
ethischen bewertungskriterien wir werden
jetzt schon ganz wichtige fragen
aufgeworfen die wir auch im rahmen der
heutigen vorlesungen diskutieren wollen
ich möchte hier jedenfalls erstmal ein
bisschen problematisieren terrain geht
und noch ein frage stellt ob es sich
dabei wirklich nur um ein medium handelt
da kommt ihr das spiel
dann möchte ich hier auch noch den
begriff des virtuellen problematisieren
so wird in computerspielen virtuell
ethisch gutes oder schlechtes getan
erscheint die virtualität mit der mit
simulationen in eine sehr enge nähe
geparkt zu werden das möchte die
problematisieren trotzdem noch ein paar
zitate angesichts des computerspiels
stellt sich hier unter anderem die frage
was es heißt dass es sich bei ihm um ein
medium licht wieder bis an den anfang
der geisteswissenschaftlichen
beschäftigung mit computerspielen
zurückreichenden kontroverse ob das
computerspiel er als spieler oder als
erzählung zu klassifizieren sei das war
diesen streit zwischen neurologen und
neuroradiologen
stellt sich weiterhin die folge was
überhaupt ein spiel oder eine erzählung
ist nicht zuletzt stellt sich die frage
auch wesentlicher weise computerspiel
anders etwa als gemälde zahlen und
musikalischen werken existieren die
frage nach der existenz ist die frage
nach der ontologie von computerspielen
hinsichtlich des computerspiels stellt
sich hier die frage wie ethisch
schlechtes handeln konnte spielen wird
heller diebstahl virtuelle lüge und
virtuellem ort etwa zu bewerten sind
weiterhin stellt sich die frage dass es
überhaupt heißt und computerspielen zu
handeln nicht zuletzt stellen sich die
fragen wie sich das computerspielen zu
politischen lebens welt einerseits und
zur ökonomischen lebenswelt andererseits
verhält zum schluss noch ein zitat im
rahmen der ästhetik stellt sich nicht
allein die frage macht und kunst
charakter des computerspiels sind auch
die frage nach dessen räumlichkeit
bildlichkeit und seine effektiven
talents also hier versucht man jetzt die
theoretische die praktisch ethische und
die ästhetische respektive der
philosophie auf das phänomen des
computerspiels zu werfen ich wie gesagt
hab hier ist ein bisschen probleme
diebstahl im rahmen des computerspiels
als virtuell diebstahl zu zeigen ich
würde sagen ist ein simulierter
diebstahl weil ich eben virtuelle
realität stärker versteht mich ist ein
virtueller flug schon ein wirklicher
gestalte eben auf virtuelle und nicht
physische weise begangen wurde wie auch
immer hier kann man noch viel weiter
diskutieren ich möchte weiter gehen und
ihm weitere interessante bücher zu
diesem philosophischen thema vorstellen
hier gibt es ein buch im jahr 2012
erschienen von stephan günzel ego
shooter und der titel das raumbild des
computerspiels es geht um einen raum
bild wir werden jetzt formen der
ästhetik der raum bildlichkeit
thematisiert wenn sie sich das cover
anschauen sehen sie schon hier einen
dreidimensionalen raum der natürlich da
ist ein cover ist zweidimensional
präsentiert wird also ein bild eines
dreidimensionalen raum ist eine
perspektive sehen sie sich hier
entfalten seine zentralperspektive alles
läuft gemalt ermittelt dieses rechtecks
und sie sehen auch es ist ein ziemlich
schlechter auge hat findet decke mir
ziemlich simple decke wie unterboden und
hier so verwende die eigentlich nur aus
recht bestehen darauf werde ich noch
später zu sprechen kommt es ganz
interessant für die geschichte des und
die evolution des computerspielens
jedenfalls dürfte hier ein blick auf den
ego shooter als ihr spezifiziert hier
das phänomen des computerspiels dieses
buch sagt er widmet sich einer bild von
die gegenwärtige kam eine andrä in der
kritik steht es handelt sich um
computer-spiele in der perspektive der
ersten person im englischen first person
shooter genannt hat sich für diese
spiele unter deutschsprachigen spielern
der treffende name ego-shooter etabliert
unter der bezeichnung viele spiele
dienen diese spiele zumeist als
einschlägiges beispiel die seit geraumer
zeit geführte diskussion um verbote und
altersfreigabe von computerspielen
stichwort indizierung wie bei vielen
gesellschaftlich relevanten themen sind
auch hier jedoch nicht in erster linie
neue antworten hilfreich sind vor allem
neue fragen eine neue frage die an das
phänomen ego shooter im besonderen an
computerspielen allgemein gestellt
werden kann ist diejenige nach der form
des bildes wird also ein bild
theoretischer zugriff zum computerspiel
entwickelt vor allem aus der ersten
perspektive noch zwei zitate dass sich
beim computerspiel und bilder handelt
ist keineswegs selbstverständlich
da unser bild zumeist eine statische
darstellung verstanden auch die
computerspiel theorie hat deren
bildlichkeit bislang kaum zum thema
gemacht seit ihnen diese aufgrund der
durch den computer ermöglichen
interaktivität abgesprochen doch das
interaktionen bildlichkeit sich nicht
ausschließen kann gerade die
grundschulen angezeigt werden da diese
sich elemente zu nutzen machen die den
kernbestand der europäischen
bildgeschichte definieren es handelt
sich um die elemente des
perspektivischen bildes zu denen
insbesondere die realistische
darstellung die zentralistische
projektion und die kohärente
raumaufteilung gehören realistischer
stil subjektive perspektive und die
damit einhergehende form von
räumlichkeit definieren gleichermaßen
die kunst der neuzeit wie auch das
phänomen des ego-shooters eine ganz
überraschende these hier wird der
ego-shooter das mitunter killerspiel in
eine kontinuität zur erhabenen kunst der
neuzeit gebracht starke thesen die er
mit der renaissance eine
zentralperspektive gemeinden angesetzt
wird noch ein zitat ego-shooter lassen
benutzer das computerspiel bildes die
erfahrung machen
wie es aussieht ich zu sein dh wenn ich
sehe video-dateien ich sehe doch im
unterschied zu den zentral
perspektivischen tafelbildern können die
betrachter des computerspiels die
erfahrung dass die jüngsten der
erfahrung des handels kombinieren und
sie müssen es auch wenn sie das bild
spielen wollen von hieraus ergibt sich
eine zentrale these der untersuchung
nämlich das ego shooter trotz ihrer
traditionellen elemente eine bild
erfahrung bieten wie sie in dieser weise
durch kein anderes medium gemacht werden
kann zur besonderheit der spezifischen
erfahrungen tritt in erster linie der
raum bei den first person shooter
bildlich bereitstellen der raum ist
nicht nur durch die geometrische
konkurrenz ausgezeichnet oben treiben
durch ergänzende ansichten mit dem
paradoxerweise eines der elementaren
merkmale konterkariert wird die
perspektive als hier noch mal ein bier
theoretischer zugang der das phänomen
des ego shooter sind eine ganz lange
ästhetische tradition stehe die frage
ist jetzt wirklich sitzt dieser bild
theoretisch zugriff dem phänomen des
ego-shooters speziell oder dem phänomen
des computerspiels gerecht ich meine nur
teilweise glaube wir brauchen wir noch
ergänzende perspektiven auf dass
computerspieler eine solche perspektive
ist die dimension und virtuellen
realität wie jetzt in einfachen
anführungsstrichen weil sie anders
verwendet wird als ich es in der
vorlesung getan habe ich möchte immer an
artikeln vorlesen aus wikipedia über
immersion immersion fachsprachlich
eintauchen beschreibt den durch eine
umgebung der virtuelle realität wie a
hervorgerufen effekte das bewusstsein
des nutzers
stimuli ausgesetzt zu sein so weit in
den hintergrund treten lässt
dass die virtuelle umgebung als real
empfunden wird ist der grad an immersion
besonders hoch wird auch von präsenz
gesprochen sie kennen das alle wenn sie
in einem film sitzen und plötzlich ganz
drin ist im kino oder weil alles
projektiert ist auf diese leinwand um
sie herum ist es dunkel phänomene der
immersion natürlich auch entstehen wenn
sie ein buch lesen und ganz in das buch
versuchen kannst sind haben diese
geschichte da kommt dann wieder gern
nach aktive charakter mehr zu
vorzugsweise zu sehen der sie in die
erzählung mit einbezieht im unterschied
zur passiven filmischen immersion
erlaubt es die virtualität eine
interaktion mit der virtuellen umgebung
wodurch eine wesentlich höhere
intensität der immersion erreicht werden
kann ok wird jetzt also
die virtuelle realität wie sie hier
genannt wird von computerspielen als
eine größere intensität von immersion
charakterisiert man spricht von einer
massiven virtuellen umgebung in mörse
virtual environment wenn es den
benutzern möglich ermöglicht wird direkt
mit diese zu interagieren das ist
sicherlich der fall bei computerspiel
ganz klar das muss man sich allerdings
fragen ob computerspiele wirklich
adäquat im sinne von immersion
charakterisiert sind und hier möchte ich
nochmal verweisen auf dieses buch cyber
places von tobias völlig kaufte sich
schon mal eingegangen bin untertitel
philosophische annäherung an den
virtuellen ort der behandelt jetzt
computerspiele nicht nur computerspiele
er behandelt alle möglichen phänomene
der virtuellen realität nicht unter dem
gesichtspunkt des bildes wie die bücher
die ich zuvor zitiert aktionen unter dem
gesichtspunkt des raumes noch zwei
zitate angesichts der detailreichtum
moderne computerspiele deren zugrunde
liegende technik auch bei computer
animationen in spielfilmen wundert
werden kann scheint es so als seine
immersion oder gar eine verwechslung der
virtuellen welt mit dem material
realität gerade deswegen so marin diese
haltung und erstellt also das besagt
darstellung den spieler der täuschung
erlegen lässt er befinde sich nicht in
einer spielwelt von einem ort dem
materiellen wirklichkeit und das stellt
jetzt für mich keine frage wie sind sie
uns theoretischen zugang zu
computerspielen um dies zu widerlegen
gibt minecraft das computerspiel
minecraft ein vorzügliches beispiel
gerade durch seine verweigerung
zeitgemäßer grafik im sinne des brockens
stils gerät der spieler nicht und die
situation die spielwelt für die
eigentliche lebenswelt zu halten dennoch
nimmt er sie als kostet konsistente
behält die unserer natur narren vom ist
nachempfunden nicht im sinne eines
abbildes das als solches äußerst
miserabel wäre sondern als
künstlerisches bild ich möchte ihnen
jetzt mal hier eine bewegte szenen
dieses spiels minecraft demonstrieren
dass sich ein bewegtes bild machen
können
geniert es ist eine sequenz wiederholt
sehen dass aus der ich perspektive da
läuft ein schweinchen vor einem rosa
aber in bauklotz ästhetik alles in
diesem spiel minecraft ist ein bauplatz
ist tätig gehalten und alles kann
argumentiert dass diese bauklotz ist
tätig deswegen eingesetzt wird um zu
signalisieren es geht hier nicht um
simulationen nachbildung einer
vorgegebenen realität sind stellt eine
eigene realität eine bauklotz realität
da das ist seine argumente dass hier in
version gar keine rolle spielen muss
durch simulationen seien hier verorten
wir uns in diesem virtuellen raum hinein
der seine künstlichkeit selbst
reflektiert finde ich interessant ist ja
das möchte ich mal in ausgehend von ein
paar stationen der
computerspielgeschichte eine entwicklung
aufzeigen eine evolution könnte man
gewissen sagen die sich in den letzten
jahrzehnten ereignet hat und die doch
jetzt wirklich auch zur
kunstgeschichte zählen darf
zukunftsgeschichte computerspielen
beginne mit diesem spiel das kennt
sicherlich alle dreimal dürfen sie raten
wie dieses spiel heißt wissen sie
bestimmt ist das spiel pong jetzt hier
muss die version 9 72 es gibt debatten
ob schon älter ist ganz simples
spielprinzip
das so hat eines der ersten
computerspiel ausgesehen es gab
vielleicht noch vor vorgänger das ist
zumindest eines der ältesten spielt man
sie ganz simpel es geht darum hier einen
virtuellen ball in das tor also über die
äußerste linie des gegners zu bringen
und mit hilfe dieses weisen schiebers
mir mehr oder weniger den man selbst
händisch kontrollieren kann das zu
verhindern und durch abprallen dieses
balles team zurück zu schießen da oben
ist der zählerstand ja also nachts um
art fußball spielen ganz primitiv ist es
geht es weiter das spiel kennen sie
vielleicht auch eine sequenz die sich
wiederholt
kennen sie bestimmt ich habe es noch
gespielt damals das ist commander keen
aus den frühen 90ern
das ist ein so genanntes jump'n'run
spiel das zweidimensional ist hier bin
ich nicht aus die ich perspektive
sondern aus der außenperspektive sein
sidescroller das bild bewegt sich auf
einer achse im
horizontalen aber ich kann mich selbst
nach vorne laufen ich kann nur noch
links überreichten ich kann auch ein
bisschen hineinlaufen dieses haus aber
es ist eigentlich ziemlich auf diese
links rechts ebene gehalten manchmal
kann man nach oben springen noch über
hindernisse aber das war's damit er
kommt wenn man kann schiessen wie man
sieht es gibt hier objekte die man
abschließen kann es spiele ist jetzt
nicht sonderlich brutal weswegen es auch
nicht infiziert wurde
anders jetzt aus mit dem anderen spiel
auch für denselben herstellung dieses
spiels oft werden das ist jetzt
wolfenstein 3d aus demselben jahr hier
sieht man es ist schon ein bisschen
portale und nichts mehr so niedlich
lieblich von hier sieht man das bild
eines
entschlossen dreinblickende
mannes der eben dieses ego hier
simuliert und wir aus dieser sicht
dieses mannes hätte das spiel spielen
gesehen für uns eine waffe in der hand
und wir sehen hier befand sich räume und
das ist diese perspektive die auch
diesen titel bild ego-shooter
zugrunde legen alles ziemlich schlechte
perspektive
die hier eben realisiert wird dieses
spiel wurde recht bald nach seinem
erscheinen in deutschland dann selbst
490 infiziert und erst 2019 vom index
geholt und der grund war der das ist
einerseits brutal war andererseits auch
symbole enthielt die
verfassungsrechtlich höchstgradig
verboten waren als hakenkreuz und so
weiter spielt eben in der zeit des
nationalsozialismus und man musik gegen
nazis kämpfen
ein grund war eben der das ist solche
symbole tieren deswegen wurde das
medizin ein weiteres spiel werde ich
ihnen gleich noch vorstellen ich möchte
jetzt hier kurz auf die technik hinter
diesem spiel wolfenstein kurz zu
sprechen kommen und zwar haben sie
gesehen ist keine wirkliche 3d technik
das ist alles noch ziemlich 2d wenn wir
jetzt auf die bildlichkeit dieses spiels
reflektiert das hat einen einfachen
grund diese rechner der damalige zeit
war noch nicht in der lage so ganz
komplexe 3d grafiken zu erzeugen mit
polygonen und wie man das alles nennt
sondern man hat sich hier eine ganz
cleveren technik bedient nämlich den
sogenannten ray casting diese bilder
habe ich auch von wikipedia und geht so
aus man nimmt hier einen standpunkt dass
die ich perspektive und werden strahlen
ausgesendet die eben dann sein
kollidieren mit imaginären grenz
objekten die mehr oder fehler vom
bezugspunkt liegen können und die dann
eben durch diese nähe und ferne also
durch die länge dieser strahlen
umgerechnet dann hier einen teil der
nationalen raum ergeben hier sieht man
also hier die verschiedenen farben blau
grün
violett orange und das ganze kann man
sich dann auch so damit denken durch
projektion rast hat sehr viel
rechenleistung gespart und hat eben mit
hilfe von 2d grafiken einen
dreidimensionale pseudo dreidimensionale
grafik ermöglicht ein anderes spiel ist
das spiel krieg und 1996 hier sehen sie
hier hat nichts mehr mit diesem casting
effekten zu tun ist hier ist es wirklich
ist 3d hier hat man wirklich 3d objekte
politik polygon hier sieht man auch
lichteffekte
dieses spiel wurde auch indiziert würde
dann wieder vom index genommen vor
einigen jahren also man sieht die
spieler waren damals als ziemlich brutal
in deutschland zumindest eingestuft
worden quetta ist ein cache ist ein
wirkliches ein meilenstein der
computerspiele entwicklung weil auf
dieser engine also auf dieser
softwarelösung für die grafik ganz viele
andere spiele passiert ich möchte ihnen
einen überblick geben aus diesem buch
von herrn günzel also hier es gibt hier
wirklich also straight von 96 ganz
verschiedene modifikationen
für die die sich genau damit
auseinandersetzen wollen ich gehe mal
hier auf der rechten seite half life aus
den späten 90ern glaubens 98 ein
riesenerfolg wurde auf dieser engine als
auf dieser grafik lösung mit dieser
grafik realisiert nachfolgeprojekt zwei
quiz quake 4 ganz viele andere spiele
haben auf dieser grafik angesetzt also
wirklich ein sehr sehr sehr zentrales
spiel und auch eine sehr zentrale spiele
technik die dahinter steht weil hier
eben nicht mehr nur zweidimensional
gearbeitet wurde sind wirklich
dreidimensionalen objekten also eine
hohe realitätsgrad wurde hier erreicht
haben
jetzt möchte ich noch die neueste
entwicklung zeigen das ist die an real
engine 5 die es noch ein paar jahre alt
was ihnen hier auffällt ist hier geht es
einerseits und die plastik die man hier
sieht sehr plastisch und diese
plastizität wird durch besonders
elaborierte lichteffekte reicht das ist
jetzt nicht ratings raytracing so nennt
man diese grafik technik also wo eben
besonders aufwendige lichteffekte
berechnet werden und dargestellt werden
können wirklich sehr realitätsnah
erscheinen aus dem jahr 2020 die neueste
version von unreal engine
ja das war jetzt ein kurzer nutzung
mehrerer durchlauf durch die geschichte
nur einige computerspiele vor allem
derjenigen die aus dieser perspektive
handeln ego shooter und jetzt möchte ich
das mal zusammenfassen was wir uns jetzt
hier überlegt haben ästhetik der
digitalität ich möchte diese phänomene
die wir jetzt diskutiert haben auf den
betrieb der digitalität zurückbringen
computerspiele gelten so kann man denke
ich sagen nicht mehr nur als
zeitvertreib und nur als spielerei
nutzloses sondern sie werden immer mehr
als ästhetisch und philosophisch
interessante phänomene ernst es muss man
sich fragen warum sind die philosophin
schützt ist nicht so interessant
computerspiele sind nicht nur spielerei
und konsum medien ich möchte jetzt
argumentieren gegen eine auffassung von
computerspielen als medien generell
zumindest muss eine medien pro bleme
avisieren und schon gar nicht würde ich
sagen dass es konsum medien es gibt
sicherlich manche computerspielen so
viel muss ich sagen die nur zum
zeitvertreib
betrieben werden ohne frage vielleicht
auch für viele aber es wäre nicht
gerecht alle computerspiele unter dem
gesichtspunkt der konsum medien
abzufangen verzieren das ist mir ganz
wichtig computerspiele sind und das ist
jetzt meine these sind
experimentierfelder sind nicht zu sehen
medien sondern sind experimentierfelder
auf dem spielerisch die verhältnisse von
realität simulation fiktion und illusion
erprobt das scheint mir viel
angemessener zahlen aus philosophischer
perspektive als computerspiele unter
bild theoretischen marathon logischen am
simulations- theoretischen oder medien
theoretischen perspektiven zu beleuchten
sicherlich wenn man sie unter simulation
systemischen gesichtspunkten betrachtet
kommen hier auch noch andere modi und
spielen das ist ganz wichtig nicht nur
simulation ist sie entscheiden
computerspiele könnte man sagen sind
simulationen von fiktionen also
fiktionen kommen immer auch ins
computerspiel rein das hat wieder eine
nähe zur nation also hier werden ich
entwickelte kommt etwas fantastisches
ins spiel was eben simuliert wird es
wird nicht realisiert
einfache der im computerspiel
simuliert wird ist kein echter kracher
es ist ein simulierter drachen manche
würden sagen dass ein virtueller drache
in jemand bisschen vorsichtig weil ich
virtualität doch stärker verstehen
computerspiele sind insofern bestandteil
einer kultur der digitalität als in
ihnen das problem virtuelle realität
spielerisch verhandelt hat ich denke so
viel kann man sagen virtuelle realität
wird vielleicht nicht ängsten sie dort
exemplifiziert aber sie wird spielerisch
diskutiert und verhandlungen im rahmen
einer kultur der digitalität können
computerspiele aber zu virtuellen
realitäten werden sodass ihr simona
tiefe und fiktiver charakter in den
hintergrund rückt wann zum beispiel dann
wenn computerspiele nicht mehr nur
simulationen darstellen wie jetzt
autorin spiele so als ob ich jetzt in
einem auto sehsinn sondern wenn wir
mittels computerspiele andere dinge
realisieren wenn wir zum beispiel gegen
andere spieler spielen und hier gewisse
virtuelle fähigkeiten erproben die wir
vor allem eben virtuellen vollziehen
können wenn wir zum beispiel
avatare benutzen die uns in einer
gewissen weise ausdrucken und damit eine
virtuelle welt mit anderen computer
spielerinnen und spielern interagieren
gewissermaßen auch währungen dann dort
kaufen die einen wirklichen wert haben
dann drücken wir der virtuellen realität
im computerspiel thema mehr
computerspiele sind gewissermaßen
dynamische kunstwerke deren rezipienten
zu produzenten werden es auch noch ganz
wichtig das spricht jetzt gegen die
ansicht von computerspielen als bösen
konsum medien zumindest gemeldet viele
computerspiele sind aber eben nicht alle
computerspiele sind nicht nur so zu
denken dass wir jeweils rezitieren
passiv wie zum beispiel wenn wir einen
film anschauen sind wir werden hier
selbst zu gestalten dieses films also
wir bekommen die erzählung nicht
vorgesetzt vielleicht teilweise
vorgesetzt durch eine story aber wir
können in dieser story wenn sein gutes
computerspiel ist immer noch selbst
aktiv werden und die geschichte
verändern das heißt wir werden hier
gewissermaßen
mit einbezogen wir werden von nicht mehr
zu finden sondern produzenten im
rezitieren des computerspiels
produzieren wir oder realisieren wir
fassen das macht sie so spannend
künstliche intelligenz zum schluss noch
wird auch immer mehr teil von
computerspielen also wenn wir gegen ein
computerspiel gegner einen virtuellen
gegner kämpfen dann muss er kam ins
spiel kommen und zwar sehr elaborierte
künstliche intelligenz die
so gut sein müsste dass sie uns bis wir
sehen das schon bei schach spielen wenn
da auch keine gegen den spieler den
spielerinnen der menschlichen spieler
mit spielerinnen gewinnt
das war es jetzt in der heutigen sitzung
über den zweiten teil der ästhetik
computerspiele und virtuellen realität
und der digitalität am beispiel der
computerspiele in der nächsten sitzung
geht es jetzt um die anthropologie der
digitalität und darunter verstehe ich
die zum einen die frage inwiefern die
digitalisierung den menschen verändert
das meine ich jetzt nicht nur im
soziologischen hinsicht sondern
wirklichen anthropologischen sinne und
die andere frage ist inwiefern die
digitalisierung nicht viel mehr als eine
veränderung des menschen ein ausdruck
des menschen ist alles die frage ob ich
die digitalität immer schon teil der
menschlichen realität war auch vor dem
aufkommen von moderner computertechnik
ich glaube man kann dafür argumentieren
aber auch hier schreibt mir wieder der
begriff des virtuellen die virtuelle
realität ein ganz zentraler schlüssel zu
sagen danke ich mich für die
aufmerksamkeit und bin gespannt auf die
diskus